maidana
plaza de la independencia la invasión
rusa de ucrania ha comenzado hace unas
horas
quien está aturdida
y no tengo control sobre la situación
los demás y yo no sabemos qué hacer
desde las seis de la mañana la gente
empezó a huir de kiev la ftc y
todos los que pudieron software de aquí
a buscar mucha gente en las carreteras
los rusos atacaron varias zonas del país
con apoyo aéreo jarquín gerson y
mariupol son algunas de las ciudades que
han sido bombardeadas en las últimas
semanas pero los ucranianos
resisten la victoria relámpago deseada
por vladimir putin no se producirá la
población vive al ritmo de las sirenas
en kiev como en cualquier otro lugar
suenan varias veces al día
imitando a los ucranianos a protegerse
en los refugios antibombas ese día a la
capital sale de un estricto toque de
queda de 36 horas por lo que a pesar de
la alerta esperan frente a los pocos
comercios que siguen abiertos
mi marido tuvo un ataque al corazón
así que necesito medicamentos y no todas
las farmacias están abiertas
no se puede predecir nada tenemos
nuestros altibajos es muy difícil
sentirse así
especialmente cuando tienes que hablar
con tu familia con tus hijos
hay que mantenerse fuerte y mostrar que
se siente miedo fright cuando realmente
lo tenemos
debido a los combates se cree que unos
tres millones de personas ya han
abandonado a ucrania y se calcula que
hay dos millones de desplazados en el
país según las naciones unidas en la
estación de kiev algunos trenes siguen
funcionando
para los demás el camino es por
carretera pero el viaje es peligroso
los rusos pueden atacar en cualquier
momento hay muchos retenes los
ucranianos en edad de luchar tomaron las
armas
él era abogado antes de la invasión
ordenada por moscú
no somos los agresores solo queremos
defender nuestra tierra
estamos tratando de organizarnos se han
recibido armas se están entregando a la
gente pero no hay suficientes para
defender todas las zonas somos un
ejército de 40 millones de ucranianos de
verdad nuestra fuerza está en nuestra
mente todo el mundo quiere ayudar la
gente nos trae comida y trata de darnos
todo lo que necesitamos
a unos 30 kilómetros de distancia en una
zona todavía libre de combates
sergei se prepara para pasar la noche
solo en un hotel
decidió volver a kiev a pesar del
peligro
una decisión difícil de explicar a sus
padres
por qué hace esto putin porque hace
llorar a nuestras madres hoy he hablado
con mi madre que ella entiende por qué
tengo que estar en kiev mucha gente
ha huido de la ciudad
como resultado algunas personas tienen
que quedarse la uned
y venderla
sigue
sergei es ingeniero desde la invasión ya
no trabaja y sólo piensa en ayudar como
puede
creo que no tengo derecho a matar a otro
hombre
pero si tengo que hacerlo
si los rusos entran a tomar kiev no sé
cómo reaccionaré
en eso
se despierta al amanecer y está listo
para partir él y sus amigos tienen que
llevar medicinas y comida
un amigo debe recogerme aquí pero ya no
contesta el teléfono al ser de michael
no se puede estar muerto
forma parte de las fuerzas de
autodefensa de la ciudad
territorial de friends of the city
puede pasar cualquier cosa
bien entonces tendré que caminar hasta
aquí
se va solo mientras que muchas familias
van en sentido contrario
en la carretera se forma filas frente a
las gasolineras la gasolina se ha
convertido en un bien escaso y sobre
todo esencial para la huida como tantas
otras esta familia traumatizada tuvo que
dejarlo todo
atacan indiscriminadamente
independientemente de la nacionalidad la
lengua o la raza yo soy rusa y armenia y
los rusos intentan matarme porque amo a
ucrania donde vivo
los rusos bombardean la ciudad de vidas
cerca situada a 80 kilómetros de kiev
que intentan rodear las fuerzas
ucranianas patrullan constantemente
viste an a los saboteadores rusos
los rusos pensaron que iba a ser fácil
como cuando tomaron crimea
que iban a poder
ocupar nuestro suelo ucraniano sin ni
siquiera tener que disparar un tiro pero
no va a ser así
quiero dirigirme a los soldados rusos
resisto chicos
bien hecha
y verán qué bien lo recibimos
el ingeniero sergei finalmente logró
llegar a quien nos envió vídeos de los
alimentos y las medicinas que están
distribuyendo
estoy muy orgulloso de todas estas
personas que han creado todo una red de
apoyo a nuestros ciudadanos
a nuestros militares y a las fuerzas de
defensa del territorio
me conmueve mucho de la cantidad de
gente que participa que no duerme lo
suficiente
robinho y del sur germano pero que hace
todo lo posible por ayudar
estatus virgen de su red también ayuda a
civiles a utilizar los corredores
humanitarios para escapar de kiev
dirección polonia o moldavia los hombres
deben quedarse y luchar es la ley en el
puente entre ucrania y moldavia se ven
mujeres y niños estas familias a menudo
no saben a qué país de europa irán sobre
todo sueñan con poder volver algún día